Je travaille comme menuisier à Hanana de huit heures du matin jusqu'à
Il est cinq heures de l'après-midi et mon père travaille comme menuisier. Je suis psychologiquement bouleversé.
Mes acres sont ici, je travaille depuis huit ans
Il y a huit ans jusqu'à maintenant, j'ai 13 ans
[musique]
Il y a une augmentation continue du nombre d'enfants à cause des guerres
Et les conflits internes qui éclatent dans la région
En raison des déplacements survenus, notamment dans les gouvernorats
Ce à quoi j'ai été exposé
L’invasion de l’Etat islamique nous est certainement arrivée
Familles de loisirs selon les pays qui leur sont attribués selon les pays
Nommé
La mère a été obligée de laisser son fils travailler pour...
Il aide avec ça
Augmentation du revenu familial
[musique]